ماك الذي اسكت هو اسم الحساب الجديد الذي
انشاه الصحفي رائع ماك على منصه تويتر بعد
ان علق الى الماسك حسابه
القصه لم تبدا بمكه بل بدات بحساب وهمي
نشر روابطه تتبع لطائره الون ماسك الخاصه
ليصدر الملياردير الامريكي سياسه جديده
باسم الدوكسينج او اصدقائي المعلومات
والوثائق الحساسه المتعلقه بالاشخاص او
المؤسسات واعاده نشرها على الملف
رقعه تعليق الحسابات بدريعه انتهاك
السياسه الجديده اتسعت لتطال صحفيين
تابعين لمؤسسات عده سي ان ان وال واشنطن
بوست القاسم المشترك بينهم هو ماسك اذ
يوغطون بشكل مستمر مستجدات تويتر واخر
اخبار مالك الجديد
انتقادي طول الوقت امر جيد لكن الاستقصاء
عن موقعي في الوقت الفعلي وتعرض عائله
للخطر ليس كذلك
دوكسينج التي اعتمدها ماسك لحمايه خصوصيه
مستخدم تويتر بحسب وصفه تعرضت مع تصريحات
الملياردير السابقه والتي اكد فيها فتح
باب التعبير والحريه المطلقه في فضاء
الطائر الازرق وفقا لمسرحت به المؤسسات
الاعلاميه المعنيه بتعليق الحسابات
ان تعليق الصحفي هارويل على تويتر يقود
بشكل مباشر ادعاء ماسك بانه يعتزم تشغيل
تويتر منصه مخصصه لحريه التعبير
ازمه تتعاقبوا على تويتر في ظل ادارته
الجديده تودي بالمنصه الاكثر شعبيه الى
مصير مجهول وغير مضمون عدا عن الازمه
الماليه الناجمه عن انسحاب المعلمين تصبح
ميزه حريه التعبير على تويتر محل لشك ابو
عمر العربيه